this week on brian ross investigates
what's going on inside
i'm sorry we've just been fighting this
morning the chilean police body cam
videos of gabby petito and i was
apologizing to him saying i'm sorry that
i'm so mean
allegations of domestic abuse but her
boyfriend was not arrested
what should officers have done what do
officers do in other jurisdictions
two top domestic abuse experts take us
through the case
plus parents anguish their college
student daughter samantha got in the car
she thought was her uber ride home it
was not
drives off and that's the last
time that you know we could see her on
any kind of video now marcy and seymour
josephson are making it their mission to
prevent what happened to their daughter
from ever happening again if she said to
the driver you know what's my name and
he couldn't respond to it correctly then
she wouldn't get in the car the a is for
ask
ask what's my name
and this week's winners and losers in
the meeting see if you agree with the
choices made by the editors
i need uh the two of you to step up for
a second okay and and uh and we're gonna
bring you back later
yes
from the law and crime trial
this is ryan ross
good evening and thank you for joining
us and welcome to our friends on
facebook live i'm brian ross joined as
always by my colleague here at law and
crime rhonda schwartz and rhonda we
begin with what appears to be another
sad story of domestic abuse that led to
death and one questions about whether
the police could have done more to
prevent it and of course we're talking
about the case of gabby petito and her
boyfriend brian laundry rhonda
that's right brian and these police body
cam videos from moab utah show the
chilling moments when officers arrive to
investigate but then leave without
making an arrest
it was the last time gabby petito was
seen alive
you want to tell me that's fine
yeah i don't know it's just
some days
a really bad ocd and i just
i was just queening and fading up back
the van before and i was apologizing to
him and saying i'm sorry that i'm so
mean because sometimes i have ocd and
sometimes i just get really frustrated
not like me and foreign
to get a better understanding of what's
happened here we're joined by kenneth
nunn associate director of the center
for children families at the university
of florida and a law professor there and
anne brevner a trial lawyer in seattle
and former prosecutor there and before
we get to you let me show you one more
clip where the police say they're not
going to make an arrest
i've decided i am not going to cite you
for
domestic violence battery okay
it was only going to be a
class b misdemeanor
however
the domestic violence portion of it
enhances it
makes like a major pain in the butt
especially you're 22 right
so i'm choosing not to say you today
so you are not going to be charged with
immigrants
all right but this is what i do have to
do
i am separating between tonight
and ed brenner let me start with you
what police what should police have done
in this case do you think
well i think they should have at least
cited him are
it didn't get to a mandatory arrest in
terms of actually taking him into
custody but under utah law they had a
citizen reporting that he had struck her
and and so basically they should have
separated them to where they could get a
better story from her about what really
happened but under utah law
the use of the word shell and the
statute says if there's probably cause
to believe there's domestic violence
there shall be a citation or some type
of uh arrest
you get the true mandatory um arrest
where there's an injury a weapon or
continuing abuse you know probable cause
to say this continuing abuse
so this is a very difficult case would
there be discipline against the officers
uh there could be could there be
liability maybe
and professor ken then let me ask you
and i'll show you this other clip where
police actually have a complication
because uh her boyfriend says he was the
one who was attacked look at this
you want to tell me about those
scratches on your face she hit himself
on her hand that's why i was pushing her
away because i
she wanted me i like the keys so i could
walk away i said let's just take a
breather and let's not you know go
anywhere let's just calm down for a
minute
and then she had her phone he was trying
to get the pieces that way
so professor nan let me ask you this
looking at all this how do you plea how
do you think police should have sorted
this out
well i think that that officer is
probably second guessing himself right
now feels really bad that he made the
decision not to make an arrest at the
time that he was present
but i think it's very difficult to see
that there's probable cause for an
arrest of brian
at this point in time as as the clip
indicates uh brian is the one who had
injury and he had a a rational and
reasonable explanation for why
uh you know they were fighting and why
he was you know that in fact he was
defending himself and it's kind of hard
for the officers to be able to sort that
through at the moment you've got one
person who seems to be calm and
collected does not seem to be angry the
other person who seems
uh as it's as has been reported has a
mental health issue going on more so
than being angry or upset
you know i think it's difficult to do
that i think though separating them for
that
night was the right call
uh you know it's hard to you know to
know that now you know knowing what we
know but it looks like at the time that
was probably the right call to make
and ann brevner a question for you from
rhonda schwartz rhonda
so in a situation like this
if you have the complainant the female
victim says
please don't arrest my boyfriend or my
spouse what should the what should the
police do
well that can happen a lot of times in
domestic violence cases we know that
especially when he's in close proximity
during the course of the questioning of
both of the parties i find it
interesting that the park ranger who's
been interviewed who was there the
female park ranger warned gabby that she
was in a toxic toxic relationship i mean
she must have seen something there that
would indicate that there was
victimization but i go back to the
caller the initial 911 caller who said
that he had slapped her he had struck
her and that's what they were responding
to and they had a duty to investigate i
think further should there have been a
mandatory arrest that's a different
question these are very difficult
difficult calls but you have to be
awfully careful because domestic
violence as we know can escalate into
serious injury and or death
and professor nunn as you know these
calls domestic abuse of calls are some
of the most dangerous calls for officers
what are the policies in major and
progressive police departments in cases
like this
well let me let me just agree uh with
ann's statement that
uh the officer should have separated
both parties and got independent stories
about what was going on the problem with
talking to both of them
together is that if one is intimidating
the other then you're not going to get
the full truth so i think that that's
correct that should have been done
and that was an era and a lot of these
apartments uh what happens is you have a
mandatory arrest
uh provision where if there is an
allegation of domestic violence and the
police come and find that allegation be
critical uh credible uh then they're
required to make an arrest on the scene
other departments uh as is the case here
in florida have a preferred arrest
uh provision where uh they they don't
mat it's not mandatory and i think uh
what ann was explaining in utah it's
mandatory if there's some violence used
which was the case in in this uh uh
incident
uh but uh it it is uh preferred under
other circumstances with without the
violence there's a preference for arrest
and citation uh but
those rules were put into place because
historically what would happen is the
police would show up uh they
would dismiss these domestic violence
situations they treated them as if well
you know that's what you know either
married couples or people who are
involved in a relationship do
uh and uh it was considered normal so
they didn't they didn't really take any
action and these new
innovations in the law started coming
around in the 70s and 80s to correct
that
and revenue we have 30 seconds or so but
these are tough calls for police are
they trained enough to deal with this
kind of situation
i don't know if they can ever be trained
enough they're so difficult and they're
such tough calls to make but we have to
be vigilant about these kinds of cases i
think mandatory arrests are important in
terms of state laws we have that in
washington they have that in utah in
this case that taking him into custody
on a mandatory risk probably would not
have been warranted but there could have
been something done that might have
mitigated what happened in this case or
even prevented it
all right anne brevner and professor
kenneth nunn thank you very much both
for being here tonight
well coming up next parents anguish
their college student daughter was
murdered after being kidnapped thinking
she was getting an uber ride home now
their mission to prevent it from ever
happening to anyone else again
you're watching brian ross investigates
on the law and crime trial network
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live law
and crime network with youtube tv for
all of your daily live trial coverage
legal news expert analysis and original
true crime programs subscribe to youtube
tv today and then locate law and crime
in the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle
watch lawn crime every day with youtube
tv we put you in the jury box
and welcome back we turn now to the
tragic story of samantha josephson who
died
as a student at the university of south
carolina and now her parents have turned
their grief and anguish into a campaign
to make it safer for anyone who calls an
uber or a lift to get a ride home
college senior samantha josephson
thought she was getting into the uber
ride she ordered after some late night
drinks with friends at the university of
south carolina in columbia it wasn't an
uber
he spent a lot of time
in search of a victim
and he found somebody that you know was
vulnerable and obviously
confused on
you know what car was her uber ride and
took advantage of that drives off and
that's the last
time that you know we could see her on
any kind of video the 20 year old coed
was found dead the next day badly beaten
the driver of that car nathaniel roland
charged with first degree murder he is
pure evil i pray that he feels
samantha's pain do i tell you that i've
confident complicated suicide
so
several times over the past 28 months
we the jury i'm independent guilty
roland was convicted and sentenced to
life in prison
but since then marcy and seymour
josephson have launched a campaign so
that what happened to their daughter
that night does not happen to anyone
else if she said to the driver you know
what's my name and he couldn't respond
to it correctly then she wouldn't get in
the car because with samantha
she got into the car and the back
safety locks were engaged once you're in
the car it's too late so immediately uh
we started the what's my name foundation
there have been a series of television
public service announcements
samantha was abducted and attacked
and violently killed that evening
the importance of sharing your location
friends and family to protect yourself
is so important in this day and age help
us prevent another unimaginable tragedy
what happened to sammy should never
happen again
and at the graduation ceremony where
samantha received her degree
posthumously the university president
made the point class of 2019 on the
count of three would you join me in
repeating
what's my name
my name is samantha josephson all
together
one two three
what's my name
my name is samantha josephson thank you
everybody
but the justices campaign ran into
politics when they took it to washington
trying to get a law requiring electronic
confirmation codes
the josephson say they found that uber
was working against it that is 100
percent true they said yes now they say
no
their home district congressman
republican chris smith of new jersey
continues to push the bill
well we got a pass in the house we
almost got it passed in the senate but
we added to
it to a must-pass bill and at the very
end of the session somebody at d.o.t
were not exactly sure who were able to
put the gabasha on it which was i think
uh awful it means that we do not have
the protections in place right now uh
but we're
you know we're not gonna quit we're
right back trying to get this uh
life-saving uh piece of legislation over
the government
and is uber uh on board now well it's
hard to say uh after it passed the house
uh they changed the goal posts and tried
to lobby for
additional things one of those or
revolves around the opt-in opt-out
provision we say you're automatically
part of this this
digital handshake if you will so that
you know that this is your ride and the
driver knows that this is my passenger
it also creates a permanent record
and then all of a sudden they say well
we want it so that you have to opt in so
the individual users would be opting in
no it's almost like seat belts you want
it to be as automatic as possible unless
you take the time to say i want nothing
to do with that and why would anybody do
that this is ensuring a safer ride for
everyone
so bottom line you are optimistic this
uh bill can finally pass oh yes i'm very
optimistic you know
i i read a lot of laws particularly as
relates to human rights they often take
longer than a year or two this should
have taken you know a month or two uh
but we do have buy-in from both the
speaker the majority leader it is
bipartisan and the same thing goes over
on the senate side with it you know the
top four people that run the u.s house
of representatives are all supportive
the josephsons
have really changed the culture um which
is making a difference
you know more people are aware of the
risks associated uh and you know after
their loss
they are just the most heroic people the
most compassionate people
i have ever met
for now samantha's parents are pushing
cities and towns especially college
towns to put up the sammy signs the
foundation has created you know we
called her sammy she always went by
sammy
so the stop
review all safety features
and then the a is for ask ask what's my
name
the signs are up now in the area of
columbia south carolina where samantha
disappeared
in a statement to brian ross
investigates uber told us that we
believe technology can make travel safer
we look forward to working with
legislators and stakeholders on
solutions that promote continued
innovation on safety but the company did
not say whether it supports the bill
being pushed by the josephsons and
congressman smith that would require the
four-digit electronic code match to be
mandatory not voluntary
coming up next
this week's winners and losers in the
media see if you agree with the choices
made by the editors of mediaite about
the departing saturday night live cast
member bec bet
you're watching brian ross investigates
on the law and crime trial network
time now for this week's winners and
losers in the media as chosen by the
editors of mediaite and we're joined by
aidan mclaughlin who's the
editor-in-chief of mediaite which like
the law and crime trial network is part
of the dan abrams media empire and aidan
you chose as your winner this week
saturday night live cast member beth
bennett
[Applause]
[Music]
eight seconds flat even better than last
week wow
i didn't think i could get any faster
and aiden why is he this week's winner
he's leaving the cast
he is now we decided to make him winner
because this marks the end of a long and
hilarious run for bec bennett he was one
of the most prominent fixtures on
saturday night live he was there for
eight years after uh
joining the show in 2013 and when nbc
announced the cast for its new season on
monday
bennett who memorably played mike pence
chris wallace vladimir putin was not a
member of it he is the only real you
know prominent regular snl cast member
who is leaving and uh but you know he
was eight years at the show uh he
delivered some of the most memorable
performances there and he'll surely go
on to do more exciting things now that
he is off the show um which uh the new
season i should say premieres this
saturday owen wilson uh will be hosting
for the first time and uh casey
musgraves is performing as the musical
guest
and what's the backstory in your hunch
and why he's leaving
you know i think for a while the reason
why people would leave snl is that they
wanted to pursue other projects you know
it's a fairly demanding show um you have
to you know every week uh be in the
writer's room working on it um the
reports say that lorne michaels the
executive producer of snl has given the
cast a little bit more leeway with
pursuing outside projects while
saturday night live is running um so i
think that retains a lot of the talent
that they have um but for someone like
beck bennett who's been there for eight
years
i can imagine he wants to go on to act
in other tv shows movies feature
projects um you know i think working
eight years on a show any any show is a
long time to be doing it so i don't
think there's any reason other than him
wanting to move on that he probably left
so many other great comedians have and
for uh the loser this week you chose the
abc news program the view which had a
complete on-air meltdown with two of the
hosts uh apparently testing positive for
covet 19 just before the vice president
of the united states was about to arrive
in the studio
there seems to be something happening
here that i'm not 100 aware of can
someone please surprise me of these
situations i need uh the two of you to
step off for a second okay anna and and
uh and we're gonna bring it back later
yes and we'll tell you why more
information later it's a tease we'll
tell you why in a couple of minutes
well aidan nothing like live tv
yeah i know right i mean it was really a
remarkable moment um though not one uh
that i think the view really wanted um
they had planned to do an interview with
vice president kamala harris on friday
but that got derailed by that pretty
extraordinary moment you saw there in
which two hosts of the view anna navarro
and sunny hostin were pulled off the set
in the middle of a segment because they
had just tested positive for covet 19.
um it was pretty wild and meant that the
two other hosts that you saw there had
to awkwardly kill time
while producers figured out a way to get
uh the vice president set up for a
remote interview
so it was a total fiasco and then we
found out on monday that the tests were
most likely false positives and that the
two hosts anna navarro and sunny hostin
had repeatedly tested negative and they
were back on the set on monday
it was a pretty entirely preventable
crisis that's why we made them loser of
the week because they could have gotten
the kova tests done well before they
went on air uh and so it was a crisis
that the ep of the show brian tetta
actually apologized for on air on monday
so but quite a while it's like watching
nascar you watch it for the crashes i
guess huh that's the thing you know at
the end of the day it is inten
incredibly entertaining um though i i
think just the fact that it came right
before an interview with the vice
president um you know it's not like they
were trying to fill time with uh with
some drama before a serious interview
with a newsmaking figure um so you know
it's not an ideal thing to happen right
before that sort of interview
all right well aidan mclaughlin thank
you very much for your choices zeke
we'll see you again next week and thanks
to all of you for joining us here
tonight and thanks to our great staff
here at law and crime for getting us on
the air and off the air without a hitch
[Music]
you